WILL SCOOP IT
PEPPERS ONE ON MRAZEK.
TOOK A LOOK.
FOUND IT IN FRONT OF BY THESE
THAT SHOT IS BLOCKED.
KELLY FOLLOWS UP AND MISSED ON
THE TRAPPER
AND SENDS IT DEEP. THE STOP
TORONTO CHANGING BEHIND THE
AND FORSBE..
MUZZIN.
HOLL A CHANCE TO SKATE IN,
BUT IS IT A KICKING MOTION.
CLEE OUT, BUT TERRIFIC WORK BY
THE YOUNGSTER WW
HERE.
PAUL IN, UNABLE TO LOCATE THAT
ONE WAS CONNOSTUTZLE AND THE 19.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT BLUE LINE.
SOFT PLAY RIGHTARDED HIM WITH TE
GOALS AT THEKILL, AND TWO-FOR-TE
GOALTENDING CLINIC HERE BY
ANTHTH
MOMENT.
RETURNING IN, ENNIS.
TRYING TO LEAD IT BIT.
SHARP-ANGLED SHOT IS GATHERED I.
>> Jon: MIGHT BE AN AN
ANY-- ALL FIVE GUYS HAVE GOT
IN DISCOMFORT.
OBVIOUSLY GOT AT.
OFF THE STI
NYLANDERNET.
MARNER.
LOOK WHAT HE FO THAT SCREEN.
INITIALLY WITH A GOOD SAVE BY
AROUND.
ZAITSEV
TORONTO WILL SKATE TO CENTRE.
COMPLETE THE